velino
ma
uguale
pur con pina
guardate dove te.am auguriamo in un
grandissimo parco con tantissimi animali
nella nazione di oggi è una caccia al
tesoro di tutti gli animali vanno chi
trova più animali vince ricorse la
caccia al tesoro dei pop i temibili e
conta tantissimo strano l'avete vista mi
metto poi la cartellina alla fine di
questo video per vedere quella super
mega caccia al tesoro ducale molto
dubbio vi aspetta ancora rischia ma
ragione dello scritto hai trovato cade
devo prendere anch'io devo vedere dio
bene con uno dei nostri animali
preferiti
amiamo todi ne rimani quali vostro
animale preferito scrivere commenti il
nostro allora per me è difficile solo
scegliere perché veramente un piacere
vedere basta gli 8 dove il gatto drenthe
ne scelgo un po allora mi piace il cane
il gatto il cavallo e poi mi piacciono
gli agnellini che peloso partenza
però mi piace tantissimo anche i
pappagalli quindi chi trova più animali
vincerà la challenge
avere ragione sul fatto che ci si può
sfracellare certa challenge scriveteci
qual è stato il vostro animale preferito
invece tra quelli che abbiamo trovato in
questo episodio e se questo video
raggiunge il 5 mila mi piace faremo la
seconda parte di trova tutti gli animali
di tutti tutti e io ho trovato il ruote
in lama
aveva scritto con una m e
maranello
trasmette di rob la c'è un dinosauro
gigante rosso bacio esami un popolo
non lo so che è uno degli iceberg
spero che sto pagando sia un animale
raro da prendere perché deve faticare un
po per prenderlo sono stati soprattutto
queste queste cause vorrei fare ci si
stacca pubblici di concentrazione per
esprit
dopo vediamo chi ha trovato più animali
io mobilità le vediamo chi vincerà
questa sfida e voglio sapere come si fa
ad andare qui di lato ei madrid è il
mazzo stessa vendola sta ora per
prendere cosa che sentono organi male
però magari c'è qualcosa fanno vedere
queste due passi da saprà possa vedere
tutti gli animali dove sono nascosti
lascia la parte di dinosauri vice
evitare che continuare ho fatto bene
così ragazzi
da qui posso vedere
ho visto un pappagallo ho messo proprio
che
riapre ma per chi è andato da lì quando
c'è un ponte non era un poco gamma una
cultura con toni molto io eh vabbè
importanti che ho preso un altro animale
sfracelli no questo no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e ora proviamo a salire 4 salendo vitale
vediamo che rimane troviamo
cosa ho detto di accettare animali trova
bella rajaa romano so magari simbolo ci
sono tutte le aree e bellissimo proprio
perché è suddiviso in queste aree tipo
fa c'è il deserto poi ci sono gli
animali acquatici o pestate cos'è un
dialogo e diamo così diamo pellicano che
camino
andiamo un po tra gli alberi questa
forse la giungla perché vedo un esime da
ok tu ancora non hai trovato no sto
cercando tutti i poteri molti sbagliati
i capi disco a parlare statali e ho
trovato un dinosauro ma non riesco
prenderlo e com'era riesce a prevediamo
perché dentro una gabbia tip un
tirannosauro io invece sono dentro un
albero google the throne albero questa
troverò dentro un albero che anima
ritroverò vediamo ci arrivi forse finora
mi piace tantissimo questo gioco ad
origgio chi cazzo al tesoro se avete dei
giochi da consigliarsi
pur pupina
guarda sto per prendere il dinosauro
fantastico che cos'è questo come mamma
perché tu sei parà non lo so che farà
bene non credo che chi è il vero nome
riguardi realtà allora se clicchiamo qua
nella zampa possiamo vedere ciò che
abbiamo sette su 101 animali 5 no no in
vantaggio ma sono presi questi cameleon
e
il cui peso di camaleonte mezzo ma basta
sarebbe o translate rocks ok sono usciti
a dall'alto e robe di altri due anni
dopo un altro
o presunto che si chiama braccio come di
male starebbe dinosauro tesoro braccio
e trovato il nepal denaro che carino
ottimo sto bevendo
che carino trovato ostriche italiano e
struzzo troppo commentiamo questa si
nasconde qua sopra
no non che tu lo fa quelle leone ho
trovato ad ora
cerco di nome per tempo i nonni tutti
tipo dove però prima aprendo il leone la
tartaruga l'hanno scritta turca di mare
del coniglio giacca ha
lasciato in inglese lion ok vediamo stai
già posto fresco a colmare ma rimane
nascosto la sua franco la casetta la in
atto deve esserci qualche animale anche
perché ci sono gli animali rari e poi si
sono quelli facili da trovare aspetto
trovato un con un altro cosa hai trovato
ho trovato la la prog che sarebbe la
rana che carino si possa dire
sull'albero e io ci ho provato ma la
città non riuscirebbero perché non si
può scappa
o trovate poco terminato posso credere
giocare di più dietro di loro è cosa ci
vorrei come ci vorrebbe come nella
challenge si trova tutti i popoli ci
vorrebbe il radar
per prenderli tutti un po non sto
trovando più animali non vogliono
evitare visto un pene o trovato ora così
dice slot italiano bravi bravi
guardate questo bene
che rob lowe st chiamato cameleon è
stata morti secondo un albero forse uno
scoiattolo o no ma quasi un coniglio di
nembro la metteva poverino fatto lucia è
sicuramente dobbiamo trovare un pulsante
qualcosa per aprirlo e devo prendere uno
scoiattolo come faccio sono salita sopra
un albero come faccio ora prendono
invece
troviamo da qua anch'io sto salendo
sopra un albero ma sto facendo un
percorso un po strano è un po difficile
ma non mi dire che siamo sullo stesso
albero lanci stiamo
preparando un buon magro
anti aborto alla neve vediamo che noi
troviamo poi abbiamo il movie come si
chiama in italiano non ci ricordiamo
come si chiama italiano non è il serbo è
quello più grande del cervo quello con
corna ci va male scrivetecelo nei
commenti ora non mi viene in mente il
nome al cep acer bravo vediamo questa
cosa io sono in una caverna sotterranea
e di una caverna si vede un labirinto mi
sono perso ci posso credere guarda come
fatto per derby quando hai trovato
nessuno per il momento ho trovate certo
che ci credo tentato velocissima to you
trovo niente ma io mica vadano le cave
vediamo forse ho capito come scalare la
montagna c'è tutto questo percorso in
cui è facilissimo cadere infatti
l'italia è sicuramente qualche altra
tantissimo aspetto ne trovano un
gabbiano ho visto un campione già
prender rabbia si qua dove c'è scritto
rifiuti tossici
no non è un altro quello che avevo io
che la mia può prendere alla forma di un
gabbiano ma c'è scritto bus cioè anatra
allora è un'anatra loro gambiano bruce è
bravo un gabbiano
ma questo passa vive lì dove cento a
questa parte ho capito è super difficile
ma davvero che alla fine sarà qualche
animale raro
arrivando in cima a prendersi tutti gli
animali che non hai preso
non prendo io prima malusi ma sto
chiedendo sempre dalla montagna da
fiscale non ce la farà super una parte
troppo difficile
capire mi ha detto che questa battaglia
di
montagna andiamo a prendere rimane più
facile io qui questo modo vedete il
pazzo andrea
ciao 26
si fa nessun animale ancora
il
primo piano
stando all'ultimo piano cosa troveremo
ricambiando così sono ancora non siete
un po tutti gli holy money wow guardate
quanto siamo in alto
allora qui c'è come dire che non c'è
nessun animale
qui c'è dentro al camino c'è qualcosa si
[Musica]
no
ma tra un anno tra pescarina però era
tra 28
e ora
a berlino
che camera trovo del memoria di cip e
ciop comodo esplorare un po d'acqua
sotto vediamo quali aree non abbiamo
visitato sei ancora sto per palacio 6
allora la l'area dei dinosauri l'abbiamo
visitata almeno io l'ho visitata ma il
toro sei riuscito a prenderla ragione no
non so dove il toro ha provato il meglio
mi io vado da questa parte
quest'oro uomo vediamo se scopo giu ehi
ma aspettano sfracellare un momento
veramente prova a prenderlo mire fine al
cai velocissimamente ho trovato delle
altre aree che cosa
avevi ragione il toro è difficilissimo
da prendere ma io sere provera toro
vincerò io se riuscito a prenderlo no
però ci riusciva
[Applauso]
vabbè lasciamo perdere intere anch'io
dopo un po lasciando stare richiamo
all'ordine tutto pulito
senza non ristorante anzi sembra sempre
di più ristorante simbolicamente créme
trovato che abbiano non vedo che abbiamo
quello il cappiano che ha perduto la
coppa in mano che
si però c'è scritto ho fatto che qua
nella fattoria si sa nulla così animali
vediamo il cavallo quale nomi ma le
brezze quasi quanti animali hai tu io 18
vediamo io ne ho 21 sono imbalzano
giusto
perché fate il tifo team anita o tv
digitale e poi quest'episodio vediamo
chi avrà vinto private non avevo trovato
ancora il numero a qualche gallina qua
magari cosa attivato attivato qualcosa
piccola berlino che carino
la giraffa hai trovato a tutti ho
un'idea ora ogni animale che troviamo
dobbiamo fare il verso che verso fa la
giraffa e non ne ho idea non so perché
non lo fa non fare sul mezzo voto poi
c'è un asinello e chiuso qua poverino
facciamo a liberarlo cosa trovato un
altro costante ma cosa ci rimane questo
ho trovato un animale che per prenderlo
bisogna saltare attraverso questi laser
cioè non farsi toccare da questi
l'animale più perfette
perfezionato space e invece ho trovato
un passaggio segreto in questa fattoria
per poi dimenticato di fare il verso del
serpente è infatti quelle borse tentano
portante
allora devo scegliere alla porta giusta
per prendere quell'animale di che fosse
una cantina una gallina by
mara lauretano reputa referta ebbe
allora poteva prostituto alla grande ora
proviamo blu non sbagliamo rinoceronte
come farebbe un cerotto non lo so
inventa
ma è chiuso in una gabbia sì l'ho preso
rido e lo fa
così uno varotti certo del fatto che mi
manca solo una porta e poi ci stiamo
[Musica]
a questo sarebbe il
via
questo sarebbe il tavolino per chi non
è quindi non sono andato con kudlacek
orchi a allora il cattivo povertà
stranissimo fatico
continuiamo la nostra ricerca allora io
devo ancora esplorare la zona
dinosa vi sto trovando altro di malattie
lorca l'ho già presa medius e forse sua
truppa ma che cos'è
frigo ho trovato nome
tutta anche verso il parlamento non è
affatto
trovato il pd cano ma il pellicano
figo trotolo venuto anch'io
copione
e afferma non ho trovato nessun animale
ha preso costretto appartamento la
ripresa notebook non so cosa dite sì
sulla tua testa e non avete la storia
devo cercarlo ma se nel labirinto scusa
pensavo possibile
nell'asta principale con la guarda
subito
vediamo vediamo se troviamo
qualcos'altro noi qui avevo già preso
che verso il pala tartaruga center non
saprei fatti poco ma cliente anche
comunicano l'ospite che l'equipe la
brava la tartaruga la sofia la tartaruga
quindi fatto sì che no strana questa
cosa che è riuscito a prendere toro toro
toro
in un bambino e sono caduto in un
contenitore per il grano ma ho scoperto
che c'è una gallina
io ho preso un dinosauro quello che è
ripreso to braccio braccio di restauro
che verso fatto
allora si indica tauro ucciso ma non
riesco a prenderlo non so che devo fare
premerebbe secondo me noi dobbiamo
prendere in due perché ho studiato un po
il meccanismo di quello di quel di quel
sistema di rilascio della porta heller
ha detto vieni qua così si chiama
prenderemo diventi aureo mi dispiace che
non riesco a prendere questa gallina
d'acqua sopra e cosa trovato con sei
trovato che riveli trovato il conflitto
che aveva prodotto come proprietario
che fabio che verso facebook o
è che era uno che viveva un bel che per
idea
ho trovato un'altra dinosauro che
secondo me fa
solo prezzo si sta prendo anch'io così
liberiamo quel tirannosauro lì dalla
galia vediamo se troviamo altri video
tori qua c'è tra l'altro su in alto c'è
un dinosauro gigante rosso l'hai visto
chissà come si fa a prenderlo con le
tratte richiamo ci dobbiamo provare a
prenderlo e invece sono quinte una
stranissima escape room in cui bisogna
scegliere il pulsante giusta ma sentiva
da girare in tondo non è uscito quello
sì
e molto spiaggia
come ha detto parte
come spiaggia oggi alla spiaggia questo
perché oggi ha così
ritrovato quell'abilità io sono quindi
dinosauri sempre ok andiamo a liberare
il dito nella gabbia presto ok allora
aspetta che sta uscendo da questo
laghetto nero e nel frattempo sto
provando a liberare con un'altra
giocatrice e
allora due persone devono rimanere qua e
sono entrare nichile aspetta solo
rimasto incastrato in questo la gattona
erano su come uscire da ieri è tutto
buio
eccomi eccomi qui allora dobbiamo
provare io mi dimetto feriti non si dice
schiaccia ma è in schiacciate il tasto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ok ora piace il pulsante mai
dai
e ora dobbiamo aiutare anche lei che
sono in grado
portatevi finire
ok ora aiutiamo lei è perché non sta
andando nei si si è andato a è andata ok
bene spostiamo verso file di dopo aprile
è rimasto incastrato di
un pomeriggio libero
voi ma io sono cristiano presto vai ok
ok
allora che verso file di dopo quindi 1
non c'è che fra poco arriva il megalodon
ma forse dobbiamo scendere giù
nell'oceano qui per prendere il
megalodon non lo so che cos'è è meno
intensa io lo squalo quello gigante
gigantissimo
quindi arriverà qua i capi uomo credo
che casino che cosa mi devo aspettare la
spagna si è fatto allora se ti butti
rare in acqua
cominci perché sa poco ma che vi si sono
in acqua noi in acqua under tra la
munizione all'altra disfacendo poi
buttarsi tra un'isola el'altra perché ho
pensato che magari il megalodon
arrivasse lire no va bene ho scoperto
questo passaggio segreto
sotto allo stagno per ora sono renzo
ricominciamo daccapo devo e lineare
neanche chissà cosa ci sarà alla fine
allora il mega non fa parte dell'inps e
in quelle che ha proprio cioè il massimo
si prende il meglio lo re di immigrati
che orari sono tigre third alternativo
e li nega la
voce di difficoltà estrema
abbiamo l'iguana il gerbo a che saremo
né gerbo ah non lo so che cos'è la
leonessa e il gatto questi dice serval e
serva al cup il servo al cup che un
gatto
particolare tipo
oh che bello che verso farla per ferrara
nord c'è anche il pappagallo l'hanno
prodotto parrotta
cittadino comando italiano
il
kk ho trovato questo rimane chiuso che
cos'è che guarda agli lo avevo preso non
lo so che cosa che sinceramente
allora che verso farlo
ma io però non ho preso gli animali è
peggio per te ti sto per vendere a che
numero sei tu allora insomma
31 animali to 31 io ho preso adesso lo
struzzo e sono 28 anni siamo così
lontani erano giungendo dopo di carmi
trovarne altri vediamo questo accentua
sei riuscita a prendere questa gallina
no difficilissima ci ho provato però
dato sempre
favorisce ci vediamo saltando da qua
non fa
mai male
e allora devo prendere il torto e ci è
riuscito di calici questo vicina che io
non credo
verso del toro è
noto non lo fa così era un pub
ma che è quello è un cane non è un toro
ha fatto la bocca per il toro detto lo
fa
è vero il vero brava ed è questo che ho
fatto sembra più un gatto colpito da far
presa io non l'ho ancora bene allora la
diva che verso potrebbe fare lo ski che
non ne ho idea
secondo me fa così le cose che
girava
ma io mangio per questo fa però ho
sempre un verso che fa quando mangiano
no perché un suono poteva bere ma ce la
farà
pensiamo
che cosa
questo mi manca allora cosa che fa bene
collettivo e tornati adesso
devo dire anche sostenuta fra
la rarità non presa la vita mia non mi
riconosco e già preso questa
in qatar unica io provo a prenderla
è bella se un fenicottero la soprano
vedete che correndo allora ho 36 animali
di
136 ce ne sono 100 è uno fabio cielo
sono 29 in tutù riusciremo a trovarli
tutti la copriremo nel prossimo episodio
se volete vedere il continuo miracolo
hanno lasciato un bel mi piace
ora vi lasciamo
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri di
licata scuole preferita buona visione